[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
happy thursday
you tapped into the group chat live in
the blitz report app presented by
fanduel my name is cabbie richards next
to me is our betting expert
shooting like steph curry with the shot
her name is kelly stewart
and missing from this week's group chat
is the man of the people
greg ivory being a man of the people he
is with the people at ufc 261
with his favorite people namely kamara
usman
jorge mossvadall and the great chad
johnson so make sure to tap in
to br betting's ig stories to chart
their adventures
at ufc 261. g money we miss you
but kelly and i got mad hoodies for you
guys so don't worry
kelly how many hoodies did you bring to
florida oh yeah we're in florida by the
way
how many hoodies do you bring to the
state of florida 100
kathy speak for yourself i don't miss
greg this dude is literally
where i'm supposed to be and now i have
to be him
i i didn't bring any hoodies because i'm
disgruntled but i do have the
handy-dandy ipad and maybe you'll
get a little generous here and decide to
give out i don't know
i'm really mad right now okay well
listen see the clip on you can see
twitter yeah he did
yeah they're they're crashing it right
now i i have a key to greg's room so i
have
access to the hoodies that he brought to
florida so don't fear
kelly's gonna give some waste give away
some hoodies even though she doesn't
feel like it
and let's begin with our favorite bed of
the week every week
we go head-to-head with the great
charles barkley the chuckster
in chuck versus america last week we
both
put w's on the board because chuck
watches the show and that's the smart
play
let's take a look at the current
standings we are
at 11-3 and the chuckster is at eight
and six we're still
three eight and six excuse me we're
still three games ahead
of the hall of famer and as long as
we're leading
kelly's gonna give away some hoodies but
hold on just one minute there kel's
tonight we're going head-to-head against
chuck again
earlier today we asked you on twitter
who will score more points
the reigning mvp giannis antetokounmpo
or the gentleman
vying to take that mvp trophy out of his
hands
joelle embiid that is the question
here are the results america's voting 57
with joel embiid you know four of his
last five games
and beta scored 38 36
39 36 this dude is cooking right now
as philly is trying to hold on to the
top spot in the eastern conference
kelly how confident is the audience in
the comments
that this one hits embiid over giannis
this is uh not greg's handy-dandy ipad
this is actually mine so it's better
uh but every single commenter has just
been
hammering embiid i swear ever since i
put janice in there
that's all they've said we've got we've
got a couple of different guys
phillyfan21 you already know who he's
repping in this one
mayo5681 agrees with me and says giannis
longhorns 20 ooh giannis scores more
tonight
longworms 20 also says milwaukee wins i
think it's going to be a really good
game oh tanner humphrey said something
nice about me
see i knew greg was lying people do not
hate me in the comment section
uh so thanks tanner humphrey uh you can
have a hoodie see
okay there we go now i know why greg
gives out so many let's see who else
we've got here
rink rink likes embiid we've got
ray brent ryan with an e i have no idea
he likes giannis as well cam ham says
embiid okay
and uh there's a bunch of people just
typing so wait guys that's not how this
works i need
hot takes and in this particular segment
i need giannis
or joelle it's really simple stuff
so why why are you on giannis's uh why
are you leaning giannis today
in this matchup so no disrespect to joel
embiid and oh by the way i think
nikola jokic has something to say about
the mvp award between these two
that being said i feel like joelle has
just been a man on a mission
and i think that mission comes to an end
tonight against milwaukee
is going to go out and put on an
absolute clinic
okay well i'm on the other side of this
joel embiid is
in mvp mode he really wants to win this
award i listened to him in a podcast
with zach lowe the other day
and he he stressed that the mvp i know
we're not specifically talking about the
mvp
but we're talking about mvps and he's
like we got to remember
defense and defense is a critical
component
to basketball we always kind of forget
because we get so enamored
with offensive output so as embiid
is uh in consideration for mvp he's also
in consideration
for defensive mvp as well as his
teammate
ben simmons therefore i'm not going to
say they're going to put the clamps on
giannis because that's going too far
but they can contain giannis with
switching and various um
defensive um schemes so i like him b
tonight
he's been cooking the past uh the past
few weeks since he's returned from his
his knee injury
so give me give me him b to outscore
giannis in this particular matchup
uh kelly who's riding with us or or
sorry who are we going with
because we have to decide whether we'll
go with giannis or we'll go with
embiid because barclay's going to be on
one of the other
as well i want to go with the people
have spoken what am i supposed to do
just say never mind i don't trust any of
you guys it looks like the comment
section is
75 joel embiid so i guess that's what
we're rocking with as a team here
okay good job well uh america make sure
to check out
inside the nba on tnt the pre-game show
where charles barkley will make his pick
and then make sure you jump on fanduel
and lock in joel embiid to outscore
giannis antetokounmpo tonight in the
milwaukee
and philadelphia game um we all know
that the best bet in america
is the three by two kelly said it last
week fanduel is just
giving money away and if there are ever
any
technicalities or discrepancies like
dennis schroeder
hitting at three and andre drummond uh
poking his head in there for goaltending
fanduel will refund the bets like that's
it's so sick so the three by two
one of our favorite bets tonight um
we're looking at philadelphia and
milwaukee and the question is
will there be two three-pointers made in
the first three minutes of the game
last week we locked in yes milwaukee
versus atlanta
and here's what happened
pulls it up he's played by lopez solomon
hill thank you so much
bogdanovic where you at bogdanovic right
there on the wing
yes money thank you so much fellow
fellas
solomon hill boyan bogdanovic
tonight again sixers bucks uh kelly tap
in with your army we need more people so
what are they
what are they saying yes or no to
tonight's 3x2
well they better not be saying no in the
comments section drop it in here i want
to see
yeses and yeses only no bad vibes from
any of you guys
because i'm telling you this is free
money cabbie said it
vandals just like you know what we feel
bad for you guys
have free 30 every single bet i
think we're at least up 10 units on this
year if not more
all right ty queezy says yes lock it in
grim reaper 23
yes mayo five six eight one yes
colby white the goat lock it in
all sorts of guys jumping dropping in
yeses off insanity five with the gift
oh whoop i love it you guys know that
greg loves the gifts i love the gifts
too
drop in some of your yeses gold mf
nugget i'm gonna censor that one uh also
says yes
this is harder than it looks i actually
i like the passion of props
uh but all these guys everybody's
dropping yes why
because again fanduel's you know what
guys here you go
here's a fun prop bet are you in
are you in you locking in yes tonight as
well
kathy i lock in yes blindly i know it
sounds crazy but every single time we
lose one
then the next two or three in a row hit
it's just automatic for me at this point
i'm i'm locking in a yes as well i like
brynn forbes and bobby portis bobby
portis came through for us
earlier this season in a three by two
and on the other side
seth curry since seth curry got cooked
by his older brother
steph curry to the tune of 49 points the
other day
the younger brother always in the family
what's that i thought you always talk
about this family thing and here you are
slandering seth curry
i'm not i'm not slandering i'm just
saying my guy's gonna be more motivated
because
you know sonya curry couldn't have been
happy about the fact that steph cooked
the younger brother for 49 so seth it's
like let me get this started right away
me and danny green this is a yes
absolutely in the three by two tonight
philly and uh and milwaukee um so
kels you want to give out have you given
out enough hoodies or you want to keep
it moving
uh i don't know toxic boy 54 is uh
dropping in the spongebob gift that
one's been a while since i've seen that
boston versus everyone
yes grim reaper 23.
oh first of all lo max 103
saying no get out of here we don't need
that sunset vibes only isn't that what
greg
says so i'm trying to do my best for you
vibes
sunset vibes indeed um so you guys uh
while kelly's still
scrolling through the comments make sure
to check out the br betting social
channels
for the links to the 3x2 from fanduel
and ride with us tonight and don't
forget fanduel offers
three by tuesdays and three by two on
thursday so you can get your fix on
tuesdays
and thursdays every single week tells
we've been discussing championship odds
a
lot on the show and this season most of
the conversation
has centered around the brooklyn nets
and but with uh james harden
facing some recent setbacks he's out
indefinitely with a hamstring injury
do we still think that the brooklyn nets
are a good bet to win the 2021 nba
championship let's take a look
at the latest odds offered by fanduel
brooklyn that's right there at the top
plus 220.
la the the lakers at 350 the clippers
who nobody's talking about plus 700 the
utah jazz best team in the nba
by all metrics they're plus 700 and the
milwaukee bucks who are playing tonight
plus 750 philadelphia right there too at
plus
1200. uh kelly what is what does the
audience think
when we as we show up show up these
championship odds
are any teams popping up more than
others are people still riding with the
brooklyn nets
or is it one of the teams playing out of
the staples center
well we know greg's riding with the
brooklyn nets you guys get in the
comments section
let me know who you're winning riding to
win it all this year
i am not cabbie with the brooklyn that's
but i haven't been at all let's be
honest
plus this team just cannot stay healthy
james harden is a
definite giant question mark not to
mention
they don't win when he doesn't play i
mean we've been on the show for several
weeks
you guys keep throwing his name in the
hat for mvp if he could stay healthy i
could i could
talk about him as a long shot but he
cannot and without knowing how long he's
gonna be gone
i don't think the brooklyn nets are
worth a flyer as you just saw the lakers
thought that was really interesting we
were getting lots of lakers love
with the return of anthony davis tonight
i think that's a little undervalued as
well
i i would wait to see how things play
out especially
waiting on the return for lebron james
but for me
i'm still rocking with the jazz i can't
believe this team is still
six weeks later since we brought them up
getting zero
love they're gonna have home court
advantage in the playoffs
i think they can get the lakers in the
best of seven so i've gotta take the
jazz here still at seven to one
kels are you worried for people that
hold brooklyn nets tickets that
k.d kyrie irving and james harden have
only played
seven games together like we're at game
number
55 or 58 and they've only played
seven games together i think that's a
concern cabbie remember whenever you're
making a futures
bet the idea is to guarantee yourself
money at the end of the year doesn't
always mean you need your team to win
what you need to be able to do is to be
able to
put yourself in a position to either
hedge out later or let it ride
and the nets just scare me as you
mentioned
they just cannot stay healthy i'm not
saying they can't win at all
i just feel like it's a little risky
hoping and
crossing your fingers that everybody's
going to be back in time
yeah it's um it's definitely a perilous
situation when when
like at best two of the three superstars
are on the court together and not all
three
you know i gotta quote demarcus cousins
who said recently
we gotta stop with the paul george
slander the clippers have won
10 of 11 games and like your utah jazz
nobody's talking about them it's like
they're disrespecting the best team in
the nba
and the best team that plays at the
staples center paul george is averaging
33 points in his last
10 games his metric 54 48 and 90. the
guy's been playing amazing
and obviously you have all world kawhi
leonard who's also there on the wing
to help clamp anybody i i i'm holding a
philadelphia 76ers ticket at plus 1200
but i'm also going to sprinkle on the
clippers at plus 700 to come out of the
west i have
i have i've like been pat i've been
observing
until now but i'm confident what i'm
seeing from the clippers
trending in the right direction now i
like listen
i like what these and also if the
playoffs were to end today
they play the sixth seed portland they
can take care of portland
the next round they would play phoenix
they could take care of phoenix and then
in the conference finals
they face either the utah jazz or
possibly the los angeles lakers
and i think they can take care of both
of those teams so that's just my opinion
from right now today being april 22nd i
like the clippers
and i'm gonna put some money on them uh
what are the people saying in the
comments kel's is anybody rocking with
either your jazz the clippers the sixers
or are they just sticking with the front
runners
the jasmine the jazz are getting a ton
of hate in the comments cabbie
said no real playoff experience so
kind of crazy donovan mitchell probably
wouldn't like that one too much
down to earth says clippers into the
sunset
he likes you lomax 103. i see everybody
sleeping on my knicks i've been waiting
for this knicks have won
eight straight can they make a playoff
push cabs i don't know
the east is uh i think the east is a
little bit more wide open than the west
i feel like
even though i like the suns i do think
that they have a shot
i think to me it's jazz lakers clippers
is who it's gonna be
where i could see maybe the heat maybe
boston there's gotta be
one of those five four five seeds there
out of the east it's gonna surprise
everybody
we'll see i definitely think it's gonna
be a team coming out of the west though
uh let's see lakers winning
healthy they can take it all i got lots
our fearless leader joe yan
he's got himself a jazz gif let's go
excellent excellent are you giving do
you have one more hoodie to give away
or do you want to save i do i'm going to
give away a few more
uh a lot of these guys think that the
nets are going in it
i'm not so all the guy just typing nuts
over and over again
you know what i'll twill 37. he likes
the clippers with you cabbie you're
walking away from a hoodie
uh mayo5681 clippers are my second
but he really likes denver as well he's
right denver was my pick to start the
year
to win it all so we'll see finn sanity
says the 76ers joel embiid no one can
guard him
let's see how this one plays out gabby
it's going to be a fun next few weeks
headed into the blaze
absolutely salute to jamal murray out
with a with a
torn acl he's rehabbing in la he sent me
a photo the other day
he's just chilling by a marina leg up
just reading books and crushing
documentaries so
uh denver's playoff chances i've
definitely been diminished since uh the
young um
superstar from canada has been out so
salute to you jamal murray we move on
to um so greg ivory as we mentioned at
the top of the show
is predisposed covering the ufc with the
great chad johnson
they already have a clip up on our our
twitter account which is awesome
uh so kelly has a chance to steal the
steam game parlay segment
and even put a w on the board kelly are
you gonna play by
your rules are you gonna play by greg's
rules and just for a reminder
kelly's rules are like 22-1 55-1
somewhere in that
range they're really really tough
five-game five-legged same-game parlays
greg's rules are like minus
even money on a five teamer to like plus
you but greg
greg does have a w on the board let's
not forget
but it's but the degree of difficulty is
certainly
higher with the way that you play the
game kelly and lower with the way that
greg plays the game
kathy we know i'm always looking for a
home run but i did take a page out of
greg's book because i'll be honest with
you
this mavs lakers game while i think it's
going to be a great game
there wasn't a ton of value that i found
on the board but i'm going to give this
parlay a shot
regardless i'm going to take the mavs
minus three i think this line is just a
little short
bookmakers know that everyone wants to
bet the lakers with anthony davis
returning
this one moved up from two and a half to
three that tells me
some big time money agrees with me here
on the mavs as far as
some prop bets go i like luca over three
threes i wish i could have bet him over
two and a half threes
this one is a little juicy but i do
think luca is gonna keep that fire
from the last few games going from
three-point range home team
over 109 and a half points now this one
was kind of weird i had to scroll way
down on fanduel to find this one under
the same game parlay
but i really like this i actually like
the game over but i've had my concerns
with the lakers offensively as
of late but this defense that once was
is not the same without a.d fully
healthy we know he's going to get some
minutes tonight but he's
not gonna play that much and without
lebron so i like
this home team over 109 and a half
luca over seven and a half rebounds my
girl ariel text me
unfortunately you gotta choose six eight
or ten on fanduel
so she told me this look she goes cal
porzingis is probably gonna be out
if he does i like luca over seven and a
half rebounds
easy and we know that the mavs give up a
ton of points in the paint so i do not
see the lakers shooting three
if three from three if they're going to
put points on the board
it's gonna be from down low from the
paint little jumpers
so i'm taking schroeder under one and a
half threes tonight this one's a little
juicy i think it's like minus 180.
it kind of pained me to put it in the
parlay but i needed that fifth leg
so listen um a salute to jalen brunson
who plays for the mavericks who writes
often on twitter
immaculate vibes only and those are the
kind of vibes we love in the show
i'm just gonna insert a couple of
concern vibes okay
so the dennis schroeder prop he's gonna
shoot like four or five or six
shots from downtown so him going under
one and a half you are going to be
sweating that one kills like the whole
game
sweating like every time he puts it up
because those under prop bets are so
much harder to hit
because the over ones you're just
optimistic the whole game but under
it's just like this are you prepared to
sweat it out all game
i am prepared to sweat out like i
mentioned i think this is going to be a
really
good game i think the lines are tight
the margins are razor thin but
i i've not been sold on schroeder just
yet
he's got a lot to prove for me and i i
think the bookmakers are baiting you
they're just going come on let me
they're fishing you
reeling it in trying to get you to bet
this over one and a half so
i don't love the last one but again five
teamer five chambers are hard i've never
been a five-teamer in my life cabbie
that's fair no you're right you're right
and listen uh
luca had a near triple-double last night
against detroit 30 10 and nine so i
think you're in
good shape with the luca props and also
uh the mavs scoring actually let's take
a look at the ticket what are we dealing
with here are we dealing with a
with a kelly stewart ticket or a greg
average oh it's definitely a great ivory
ticket only paid
eight to one oh i know
it's not quite a g money special
yeah we'll call it g money special uh
you know taking a page out of greg's
book
since i'm here giving out hoodies and uh
try
trying to do both i'll admit this is
really hard to do with this ipad
so i got to give greg some props and
also you know make fun of him a little
bit how about this you guys drop
some greg slander in the chat because he
gets to be at ufc
chad johnson and not me so
cabbie what did i do to deserve it
that's amazing uh well now that the now
that the audience has had a few minutes
to take a look at the parlay is
are they keying in on any legs that that
cause
that have that they're concerned about
that may not hit because again this is
this is an eight to one parlay not
terribly difficult but some of those
legs are are tougher to hit than others
are have any
jumped out to you in the comments and
who else are we giving uh hodies to
before we say good night
i can tell you what i'm not giving a
hoodie to wagsworld10 kelly might go
offer
uh catch me on twitter we'll make it
those are bad vibes those are bad vibes
over
over give me a break uh he also says
right on cabbie there you go
lots of guys oh so i like snacks too
says easy money well i don't think it's
easy money
but i appreciate the good vibes uh
somebody's tagging dan marino in our
chat
not sure why he was a miami dolphin and
uh we'll see
em sanders likes mavs first half in game
i'm rocking with you there i do think
the mavs
uh getting getting a little get a little
extra bonus because
anthony davis is coming back tonight i
know that they played the pistons last
night but this is a lakers team that has
absolutely owned them
all right let's see who's left nobody i
don't want to give anybody
one one more one more and we'll say
goodbye
one more we'll do a refresh oh wagsworld
said ah
all right give the guy a freaking hoodie
be nice to me from now on all right
good vibes only good vibes only remember
what you learned here today
the 3x2 is offered on both tuesdays and
thursdays
so remember to lock it in and ride with
us tap into the br betting stories all
weekend to
watch greg ivory and ochocinco's
adventures at ufc 261
and the br community tab is still open
on
on our app so just get on bleacher as
you are right now click on
sports betting and community and fire
off some pics there i like to take my
picks
from the community tab so help me out uh
alongside kelly stewart my name is cabby
richards
we are saying goodbye and we're tapping
out of the we're leaving the group chat
take care guys
[Music]
you